[Music]
science sketches aims to create a path
from people's everyday language into the
scientific world and we're trying to get
lots of scientists and people excited
about science to make this material to
make these videos that explain concepts
so we're both enabling the public to get
to science and enabling scientists to
communicate to the public
so when you are ready if you want to try
and make your own science sketch we go
to the science sketches website and go
to this section called Creed and submit
and there's a worksheet this PDF
download and the first step is to write
a script you come up with your big
question what you want to explain the
videos have to be less than two minutes
that's one of the constraints and that
translates to about 300 words so when I
storyboard I'll read the script and
first all think of visuals that sort of
makes sense to go with the script and
sketch them out roughly so that's where
storyboarding comes in or you can flesh
out what order you're going to draw
stuff so that you don't get disoriented
when you're actually doing it another
thing you want to do is try to have a
graphic or a visual representation for
each sentence you say in the narrative
so that's also a storyboard is important
so you can look at each sentence and
come up with some kind of visual that
makes sense so you don't have any dead
space
so there are lots of ways that you can
set up your camera to film for the
sketches but the main thing is that no
matter how you tape it strap it or clamp
it you want it to be high enough so that
it can see the entire frame of the paper
that you're going to be sketching on and
you also want to make sure that it's
pretty solid so that any passing
vibrations or movements that you make
don't affect the image so it's all
wobbly and makes your viewer sick you
also want to make sure that you have
adequate lighting you can use just a
simple flashlight on your phone but you
can also go on Amazon or go to a
drugstore and find little other lights
or find creative ways to make sure that
you have pretty consistent and even
lighting throughout the entire plane of
field and one tip I recommend is to have
a glue down paper or tape that marks the
boundaries of where you can write and
where you can be seen once you set up
your camera because often times they'll
be focusing so much on the paper that
you'll move your hand in the wrong space
or write something out of field and you
always want to make sure that your
reader can see what you're doing and
then the other thing is that using your
hands is a really great way to connect
with the reader in the film because they
can see that it's somebody actually
making the video that you're looking at
but you don't want to have your hand and
arm all over the place so that you're
covering up what you actually want them
to see so remember to write and remove
to be able to express what you want to
show in your film so when you want to go
and record all your the sketch that you
made and there's a couple ways you can
go about doing it if you have any cell
phone
the recording device our board voice
memo a bomb that totally works fine it's
a lot next to your mouth like you're
talking on the phone and as long as you
can get it right and one take but that
totally works you can take that and run
with it something that we use is this
little audio recording device it's a
little more expensive but if you can get
your hands on one the audio quality is
really nice and then you can process
that audio on a variety different
platforms when you have all your footage
ready to go all you have to do is import
your images and pour your audio sync it
all together to make sure that they look
awesome I'm using iMovie to make this
cool stop-motion video which is freely
available on holdbacks
there's also a free software on Windows
and a really cool app called stop-motion
Studio which you can download as a free
app on your phone
science is only as useful as people can
understand it so I hopefully I'm gonna
be able to take some of these skills and
teach them to at least that small
portion of people who I know are
interested in science communication and
sort of keep on spreading the idea that
it's not that difficult to make these
little videos or it's not that difficult
to take a minute to explain to people
what it is that you do and seeing
results in places around the general
public is really what will make people
more excited about making them making
these sketches well our goal is really
to get as many people involved in this
process as possible so we intentionally
created a really simple format with
easy-to-follow instructions so that
anyone can tell a story about science
with the video of their own and
contributed to the growing library of
videos
[Music]